welcome back everyone this is part three
in our series on distributed word
representations we're going to be
talking about vector comparison methods
to try to make this discussion pretty
intuitive i'm going to ground things in
this running example on the left i have
a very small vector space model we have
three words a b and c
and you can imagine that we've measured
two dimensions dx and dy you could think
of them as documents if you wanted
there are two perspectives that you
might take on this vector space model
the first is just at the level of raw
frequency
b and c seem to be united they are
frequent in both the x and the y
dimension
whereas a is comparatively infrequent
along both those dimensions
that's the first perspective the second
perspective though is more subtle you
might just observe that if we kind of
correct for the overall frequency
of the individual words then it's
actually a and b that are united because
they both have a bias in some sense for
the dy dimension
whereas by comparison c has a bias for
the x dimension again thinking
proportionally
both of those are perspectives that we
might want to capture and different
notions of distance will key into one or
the other of them
one more preliminary uh i think it's
very intuitive to depict these vector
spaces and in only two dimensions that's
pretty easy you can imagine that this is
the dx dimension along the x-axis and
this is the d-y dimension along the
y-axis and then i have placed these
individual points in that plane and then
you can see graphically that b and c are
pretty close together and a is kind of
lonely down here in the corner the
infrequent one
let's start with euclidean distance very
common notion of distance in these
spaces and quite intuitive
we can measure the euclidean distance
between vectors u and v if they share
the same dimension n by just calculating
the sum
of the squared element y differences
absolute differences and then taking the
square root of that
that's the math here let's look at that
in terms of this space so here we have
our vector space
depicted graphically a b and c and
euclidean distance is measuring the
length of these lines i've annotated
with the full calculations but the
intuition is just that we are measuring
the length of these lines the most
direct path between these points in our
high dimensional space
and you can see that euclidean distance
is capturing the first
perspective that we took on the vector
space which unites the frequent items b
and c as against the infrequent one a
as a stepping stone toward cosine
distance which will behave quite
differently let's talk about length
normalization
given a vector u of dimension n the l2
length of u
is the sum of the squared values in that
matrix and then we take the square root
that's our normalization quantity there
and then the actual normalization of
that original vector u involves taking
each one of its elements and dividing it
by that fixed quantity the l2 ranks
let's look look at what happens to our
little illustrative example on the left
here i have the original count matrix
and in this column here i've given the
l2 length as a quantity
and then when we take that quantity and
divide each one of the values in that
vector to get its l2 norm
you can see that we've done something
significant to the space so they're all
kind of united on the same scale here
and a and b are now close together
whereas b and c are comparatively far
apart so that is capturing the second
perspective that we took on the matrix
where a and b have something in common
as against c
and that has come entirely from the
normalization step and if we measured
euclidean distance in this space just
the length of the lines between these
points we would again be capturing that
a and b are alike and b and c are
comparatively different
cosine kind of does that all in one step
so the cosine distance or approximately
the distance as you'll see between two
vectors u and v of dimension share
dimension n
this calculation has two parts this is
the similarity calculation cosine
similarity and it is the dot product of
the two vectors divided by the product
of their l2 lengths
and then to get something like the
distance we just take one and subtract
out that similarity
again let's ground this in our example
here we have the original count vector
space model
and what we do with cosine distance is
essentially measure the angles between
these lines that i've drawn from this
origin point
and so you can see that cosine distance
is capturing the fact that a and b are
close together as measured by this angle
whereas b and c are comparatively far
apart
so again with cosine we're abstracting
away from frequency information
and keying into that abstract notion of
similarity that connects a and b as
against c
another perspective that you could take
is just observe that if we first
normalize
the vectors
via via the l2 norm and then apply the
cosine calculation we change the space
as i showed you before so they're all up
here kind of on the unit sphere
and notice that the actual values that
we get out are the same
whether or not we did that l2 norming
step and that is because cosine is
building the effects of l2 norming
directly into this normalization here in
the denominator
there are a few other methods that we
could think about or classes of methods
i think we don't need to get distracted
by the details but i thought i would
mention them in case they come up and
you're reading our research the first
class are what are what i've called
matching based methods they're all kind
of based in this matching coefficient
and then jacquard dice and overlap are
terms that you might see in the
literature
these are often defined only for binary
vectors but here i've given their
generalizations to the real valued
vectors that we're talking about
and the other class of methods that you
might see come up are probabilistic
methods which tend to be grounded in
this notion of kl divergence
kl divergence is essentially a way of
measuring the distance between two
probability distributions
between
to be more precise from a reference
distribution p to some other probability
distribution q
um and it has symmetric notions
symmetric kl and jensen shannon distance
which is another symmetric notion that's
based in kl divergence again these are
probably appropriate measures to choose
if the quantities that you're thinking
of are appropriately thought of as
probability values
now i've alluded to the fact that the
cosine distance measure that i gave you
before is not quite what's called a
proper distance metric let me expand on
that a little bit
to qualify as a proper distance metric a
vector comparison method has to have
three properties it needs to be
symmetric that is it needs to give the
same value for x y as it does to yx
kl divergence actually fails that first
rule
it needs to assign zero to identical
vectors
and crucially it needs to satisfy what's
called the triangle inequality which
says that the distance between x and z
is less than or equal to the distance
between x and y and then y to z
cosine distance as i showed it to you
before fails to satisfy the triangle
inequality and this is just a simple
example that makes an intuitive it just
happens that this distance here is
actually greater than these two values
here
which is a failure of the statement of
the triangle inequality
now this is relatively easily corrected
but this is also kind of a useful
framework of all the different choices
that we could make
of all the options for vector comparison
suppose we decided to favor the ones
that counted as true distance metrics
then that would at least push us to
favor euclidean distance
jacquard for binary vectors only and
jensen shannon distance if we were
talking about probabilistic spaces and
we would further amend the definition of
cosine distance to the more careful one
that i've given here
which which satisfies the triangle
inequality as well as the other two
criteria
and by this kind of way of dividing the
world we would also reject
matching jaccard dice overlap
um kale divergence and symmetric tail
divergence as ones that failed to be
proper distance metrics and so that
might be a useful framework for thinking
about choices in this space
one other point in relation to this this
is obviously a more involved calculation
than the one that i gave you before and
in truth it is probably not worth the
effort here's an example of just a bunch
of vectors that i sampled from one of
our vector space models and i've
compared the improper cosine distance
that i showed you before on the x-axis
with the proper cosine distance measure
that i just showed you
and the correlation between the two is
almost perfect so there is essentially
no difference between these two
different ways of measuring cosine
and i think that they are probably
essentially identical up to ranking
which is often the quantity that we care
about when we're doing these comparisons
so probably stick with a simpler and
less involved calculation would be my
advice
let's close with some generalizations
and relationships first euclidean as
well as jaccard and dice with raw count
vectors will tend to favor raw frequency
over other distributional patterns like
that more abstract one that i showed you
with our illustrative example
euclidean with l2 norm vectors is
equivalent to cosine when it comes to
ranking which is just to say that if you
want to use euclidean and you first l2
norm your vectors you're probably just
doing something that might as well just
be the cosine calculation
and dice are equivalent with regard to
ranking that's something to keep in mind
uh and then this is maybe a more
fundamental point that you'll see
recurring throughout this unit both l2
norming and also a related calculation
which would just create probability
distributions out of the rows they can
be useful steps as we've seen but they
can obscure differences in the amount or
strength of evidence that you have which
can in turn have an effect on the
reliability of for example cosine
normuclidian or kale divergence right
these shortcomings might be addressed
through waiting schemes though but
here's the bottom line there is valuable
information in raw frequency
if we abstract away from it some other
information might come to the surface
but we also might lose that important
frequency information in distorting the
space in that way and it can be
difficult to balance these competing
pressures
finally i just close with some code
snippets our course repository has lots
of handy utilities for doing these
distance calculations and also length
norming your vectors and so forth and it
also has this function called neighbors
in the vsm module it allows you to pick
a target word and supply a vector space
model and then it will give you
a full ranking of the entire vocabulary
in that vector space with respect to
your target word starting with the ones
that are closest so here are the results
for bad using
cosine distance in cell 12 and jakarta
distance and swell in cell 13 and i
would just like to say that these
neighbors don't look especially
intuitive to me it does not look like
this analysis is revealing
really interesting semantic information
but don't worry we're going to correct
this we're going to start to massage and
stretch and bend our vector space models
and we'll see we will see much better
results for these neighbor functions and
everything else
as we go through that material
you